hay largas filas este domingo frente al
consulado de Brasil en Buenos Aires para
que los residentes brasileños en
Argentina participen de esta elección
presidencial en segunda vuelta en
Argentina según datos de 2020 ofrecidos
por la embajada hay unos 89,000
brasileños viviendo y hay habilitadas
para votar unas 12.700 personas en su
mayoría votan en este centro electoral
aquí en la ciudad de Buenos Aires hay
otros dos centros electorales en otras
dos ciudades del país y vienen aquí a
decidir su voto bien por el actual
presidente Jair bolsonaro o por el ex
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
bueno por supuesto Yahir Mesías
bolsonaro sabemos lo que hizo el PT
sabemos lo que hizo la izquierda en
Brasil y saben lo que la izquierda está
haciendo En toda latinoamérica Entonces
nosotros vamos a elegir un un presidente
de derecha otra vez más porque queremos
que siga miren cómo son Cómo son los de
izquierda miren Cómo son los de
izquierda no te respetas de ninguna
manera y es lo que está pasando en
Brasil en Brasil estamos viviendo una
crisis por eso viste Entonces no
queremos la izquierda otra vez en
nuestra nación creo que ganara
porque un candidato mejor para las
democracia por las que son de sociales
ambientales No no es fascista y creo que
a lo mejor para las operaciones necesita
y vivimos
para que Brasil ahora está bien con el
economía después de una pandemia de una
guerra está se está mejor que los otros
países me gustaría que nace porque
gobierna para el pueblo y para la gente
menos adinerada O sea un gobierno más
justo para gente que no está tan bien
monetariamente y socialmente en la
primera vuelta si bien fue mucho más
pareja la elección a nivel general en
Argentina la diferencia fue mucho más
grande a favor de Lula da Silva veremos
Entonces qué ocurre En esta segunda
vuelta electoral